己有一份正经的工作，
有什么好自卑的，
你身体健康，
你没有任何精神类的疾病，
你有稳定的收入，
你有这么好的学历，
你父母也并不是说那种说天天你要去医院去照顾，
或者说去花很多钱去给他们治病，
我感觉你现在这个状态没有什么要自卑的。
呃，
我是91年12月份的，
2023年6月份硕士毕业，
现在是在北京工作，
刚工作前两年的话，
可能工资比较少一点，
到二五年的话，
工资开始变多了一点，
现在手里的存款大概是有20个，
因为我是从高中开始就有攒钱的意识了，
大学研究生的寒暑假都在打工，
一直到工作现在一直攒着，
主要有两个问题，
第一个就是我跟我家里的问题，
第二个就是我跟我现在的第三个问题，
我先说第一个问题，
就是我跟我爸妈的关系，
个人你觉得是不太好的，
因为我从小就是被教育说我的吃穿了跟最差的比，
他是是需要和最好的比。
我刚上大学没多久的时候，
算是东窗事发了，
他拿了一个亲戚的房产证在银行贷款，
贷了100多个，
后来还不上了，
他就一个人跑了，
唯一一个家族里面比较德高望重的一个亲戚就把他抓回来了，
后来那个亲戚还有加上我家里就想办法就借了一堆。
把银行的那个贷款都还上了，
家里就是在这件事情发生之前，
他攒了一些钱，
那最体不太清楚，
大概就是几十个吧，
因为那个例子也是比较高的嘛，
都全部还进去了。
最近发生的时候，
我发了变天以后，
人经常就会在同样的圈里发，
就只有在逆境之中才知道谁习真朋友这类话，
我就觉得特别的可笑，
我大二那年寒假的时候就没回家过年，
就是那个电磁厂打工，
白班夜班两班，
早就打工，
一个多月赚了6000多块钱，
我爸就知道我去打寒假工嘛，
我发工资了，
就打电话问我借2000出了以后还我，
当时我就给他转了1500，
后来他拿了500，
刚开始的时候我还是因为他是我爸嘛，
所以我觉得我应该支持他，
慢慢的我就觉得他好烂呢，
所以我渐渐的就不怎么理他了，
他跟我说话我也不怎么理他，
他就把我微信给删了，
后来他就偶尔给我打电话，
但是我也不怎么接，
现在的话他是在广东跑滴滴，
其他的话我是不太了解，
因为很久不理，
怎么给我打电话我也不怎么接，
我妈就在家照顾我侄子，
因为2023年快毕业的时候我回家过年，
那个时候我哥和我耍才要离婚，
当时我妈就和我说，
让我赶紧找个工作赚点钱，
然后把钱借给我哥买房子，
本来我嫂子就要跟我哥离婚了，
我当时听到这个话就是火特别大，
我当时。
搞毕业的找工作压力特别大，
甚至他一点都不关心我，
后来他俩就真的离婚了，
我妈也没有结过这件事情。
我哥反正也是挺背的一个人，
他高中就毕业就出去打工了，
上大学的时候他已经工作好几年了，
我上大学加研究生的时候，
我哥是每年给我转了100块钱，
然后加起来一共700块钱。
去年他但凡买了辆车，
我刚刚工作，
他回家就找我借钱，
问我借几万，
我说我没有，
然后他说你一万都没有吗？
我说我没有。
于是只要在家的话，
我侄子就是我在带一碗，
期间的花费也是我在说。
网友怎么评价的，
说你这是在足出好损，
就你爸这样，
你哥这样还能出你这样的，
这么优秀啊。
研究生毕业了的真的是傣族出好损，
我上大学和研究生的学费的话都是我爸交的，
呃，
学费加住宿费是4500，
然后研究生学费加住宿费是一万四，
学费都是他交的，
我本科的生活费都是靠亲戚接济，
还有我妈妈给我转的，
研究生的生活费的话都是奖学金，
还有我平时兼职赚的。
第一个问题就是我现在已经工作两年了，
手里有点积蓄，
也有人知道我这个积蓄，
我爸妈跟我工作之后的态度对我特别软，
就跟之前非常不一样，
但是我看到他们现在这么对我就觉得。
在这恶心，
然后你妈要求你挣钱给你哥哥贴补，
避免他们离婚，
这个事儿说起的话，
如果是我的话，
我可能心里就膈应了，
凭什么呢？
我挣钱贴补我哥哥嫂嫂，
这样他们就不离婚，
我感觉我妈就是在用这种道德绑架的方式，
把负罪感、
罪恶感转嫁到我身上来，
我可能就膈应起来了，
我现在跟家里就是也不怎么联系过，
且的话我会给我妈发点红包，
他最近也是向我索取一些情感上的链接，
但是我给不了，
就是这么个情况，
那你现在想要问我的问题是什么，
怎么相处是吧？
对，
还有我的亲戚，
他们就也是劝我，
因为像我爸跟我哥那个样子，
我妈在家非常的辛苦，
也是劝我要先朋友就是那种，
如果你的爸爸是这种人，
他要拿别人的房子去偷偷的抵押了，
去贷款了，
欠一屁股账了，
然后他现在还觉得什么啊，
人在落难的时候才能看出来谁是真好人，
谁是真朋友，
如果你爸是这种人的话，
以后别来往，
以后你找对象啊什么的，
尽量别让你爸搀和，
你自己做主，
你该找什么样的对象，
该找什么样的国家，
该谈什么财礼，
该谈什么条件，
自己做主，
我不让你爸去掺和，
因为你爸这人的话，
就属于那种觉得全世界都欠他的啊，
你对他再好的话，
他也会愿意欠他的，
千万不能让你爸掺和你的婚姻跟。
哎呀，
不怎么跟他联系，
你问天，
就是我对我妈这里，
我不知道该怎么办，
你妈这里是吧，
他给你打电话接呀，
他问你要钱，
确实现在你这个阶段的话，
应该是要把所有的时间精力钱要砸到自己身上，
为啥？
因为你是一个特别关键的年纪，
你现在这个阶段就得穿的体面，
就得打扮的周正，
因为有老婆姐妹都是属于这种心态，
当毕业了之后就老想回报家里，
老想回报家里了，
我不认为你现在是一个好的时机回报任何人，
嗯，
明白，
我就是过节的时候会给我妈转一点红包，
那可以啊，
等能你自己的日子过好了再说，
等你自己找对象顺利了，
工作也顺利了，
各种经济条件越来越好了再说，
但这是第一个问题，
然后有第二个问题，
我跟我对象的问题，
我在研一的时候就交了一个男朋友，
他也是硕士毕业，
现在比我大一岁，
96年的那个是程序员，
他一年的话大概是在，
但是九五个吧，
自己我不太清楚，
我也不是很关心，
那家里所有的钱，
加上他这几年赚的钱加在一起加起来是有100出头，
光谈他可能不到一年的时候，
他跟我说他妈妈眼睛看不见，
当时也蛮分手，
就觉得蛮心疼于他的，
因为我早毕业一年，
毕业之候他就在北京租房子，
在北京工作嘛，
不晚一年毕业业之。
的话，
我就跟他住一起，
我刚开始的时候，
我的工资是比较少，
大概是一个月就只有四五千块钱，
一个月房租是2600，
我交500，
他的是他交，
后来搬家，
我工资多的话是我交3000，
一个季度大概是3200×3的房租，
我交了3000，
其他的他交。
生活费的话，
我们是有一张公共的卡，
他充2100，
我充900，
一个是3000块钱，
大概可以花5周。
在一起的时间长了，
我就慢慢知道他妈妈眼睛看不见问题，
是遗传性的疾病，
在一起好多年之后才知道的，
但是他说他家族里只有他妈妈一个人是那个样子，
不知道是突变还是什么原因，
所以我平时也不怎么在他面前，
其他妈妈怕伤害他嘛，
他跟他爸爸关系非常不好，
就是可能比较急的上火，
要动手的那种，
非常不好，
然后他和他妈妈的关系也特别好，
一周可能会打一个电话，
一次电话能打一两个小时，
他比较叮嘱他们妈，
他妈妈是先天的忙还是成熟了之后才忙的呢？
我今从他小的时候，
从妈妈小的时候眼睛就不太好，
具体我不太清楚，
但是我明确的问过他，
他说她妈妈那个眼睛小的时候去医院看过，
说确诊的是遗传性的一个疾病，
我跟他俩在一起的话，
我俩都属于那种家庭都不太好的，
所以可能性格。
各自都有一些问题，
我是觉得他这个人就是自尊心很强了，
性格也很犟，
眼皮特别薄，
我们今年6月30号吵架了，
一直会冷战，
今天还是没有好，
有可能就是作一下，
我就会跟他说，
我现在很难受，
你能不能哄哄我之类的，
他就会说你爸妈都不哄你，
凭什么要求别人哄你，
说这一类的话，
你们都是快30岁的成年人了，
就不应该说我吵架了，
然后我就又哄你之类的，
就是如果你吵架的话，
我跟你说话，
带你去吃饭就可以了，
就够了。
我觉得其他的事情啊，
都放一放，
这种遗传性的东西，
你愿意承担这个风险吗？
这个风险不光是在于你的丈夫将来有可能变成盲人，
还是在于你将来生个孩子也有可能变成盲人，
就是这个遗传的概率，
你自己愿不愿意承担这样的风险，
因为我们现在在一起的话，
暂时聊的就是大妈妈那个样子，
肯定是没有办法提供一点点的帮助，
到时候我们还得照顾他，
就是说以后不要孩子这件事情，
但是这件事情我觉得觉得说不好，
到了30多岁，
40多岁，
可能想法都会发生改变什么的，
所以我现在也是特别的纠结，
你要慎重考虑啊，
人跟人的选择性是很不同的，
像我的选择的话，
我记得我以前讲课那个择偶的十大原则。
排在第一位的原则是健康，
我无法想象如果我生一个孩子，
我明知道孩子的父亲是有眼盲基因的，
有遗传性的，
然后如果我生了一个孩子，
他真的是盲的，
我无法想象我对孩子会产生多大的这种愧疚心，
我把他带来这个世界上，
让他来开启这样一个模式，
我可能这辈子心里都过不去这个坎儿。
所以说我跟他之间的问题，
就是主要是谈恋爱当中遇到的各种问题，
就是小事儿，
主要还是那个遗传性的问题，
是我觉得那个问题是最关键的，
更何况我并不认为这个男生对你有多么的满意，
就是这个男生他那么能挣钱，
他有100多万的存款，
但在生活当中的话，
我并没有感受到这个男生对你有什么关照，
就是平时生活上面还是他出的消费比较多，
姑娘，
你要知道啊，
我们女人天生是自带价值的，
不管是是陪伴，
是子宫，
它都是价值，
你明白我想表达的意思了吗？
我明白你的意思就是这些价值，
她的一个非常烦你权达人，
就是你刚刚说的那些价值在他眼里都不是价值，
你居然能笑的出来，
那你也不认为你自己有价值吗？
我笑是因为我觉得他的想法特别可笑，
你再慎重考虑一下，
姑娘啊，
我明白你的意思了，
好是。
我还有最后一个问题，
我想问一下，
我如果就是考虑谈下一个男朋友，
你的内心有点亲密关系的缺失，
我非常希望有一种那个家庭的温暖，
他觉得我的这个家庭环境，
我感觉很自卑，
不管怎么说，
你的爸爸妈妈他不是说要每个月要你出医药费，
每个月要你去医院去照顾他，
至少没有给你们拖后腿，
是吧？
所以你现在这个原生家庭，
在整个婚恋市场上的话，
并不算是有什么硬伤，
或者说有什么让人家一上来就不敢娶你的，
没什么好自卑的，
更何况你自己是研究生毕业，
你自己有一份正经的工作，
有什么好自卑的，
你身体健康，
你没有任何精神类的疾病，
你有稳定的收入，
你有这么好的学历，
你父母也并不是说那种说天天你要去医院去照顾，
或者说去花很多钱去给他们治病，
我感觉你现在这个状态没有什么要自卑的，
我有一天就是焦虑症躯体化之类的东西，
如果你是焦虑症躯体化的话，
我认为你更应该离开这个男朋友，
因为这个男朋友的出现，
他只会加重你的不自信，
只会加重你的无价值感，
他不会让你变得越来越好。
明白好，
就这样啊，
明白我跟你们讲，
这个社会上有一些男生，
他骨子里就是厌女的，
骨子里他就是瞧不起女性的，
无论你挣钱比他多，
你社会地位比他高，
但他就自带。
种性别优越感，
他就瞧不起你有没有遇到过的扣一，
他可能也学历不是很好，
也没有什么很好的收入，
也没有很好的原生家庭，
但他骨子里就是有一个优越感，
他觉得他比你强，
你算什么东西？
在我面前，
他甚至既然他觉得他比你高人一等，
他就不会感受到你的那个叫什么苦难，
他不会觉得你怀着孕生的孩子，
你付出了多少，
你牺牲了多少，
在他看来的话，
你是比他更低一等的存在，
你所经历的这些有什么资格在他面前去提呢？
所以你们所有的女孩子真的找对象的时候，
要找那种有同理心的，
他最起码把你当个人，
最起码把你当个平等的物种，
他才有可能去体谅你的不容易，
有可能看到你在生育孩子、
养孩子、
带孩子这个过程当中的付出，
记得点赞关注哦。